Joe Biden continuing his Bay Area
fundraising trip on Tuesday appearing at
Event in San Francisco where he briefly
addressed news of his son Hunter Biden's
plea deal joined by joined by Gavin
Newsom which we definitely have to talk
about because there's been this huge
question about whether Gavin Newsom is
the candidate in the wings and I'm going
to pass this over to our California
expert here in a second to talk about
this let's see what he said he said
let's see more technological change he
said they finally asked him about the
justice department court filings after a
lengthy pause during which the president
looked like he wasn't going to answer
any reporters we have the story from
SFGate San Francisco gate he decided to
weigh in I'm very proud of my son that's
all he said the White House spokesperson
who told various news outlets on Tuesday
the president Force lady first lady love
their son and support him as he
continues to rebuild his life we will
have no further comment look guys this
is a story where and look I know there's
been some happy time talk out there
across the news networks across some of
conservative media Absecon and
right-wing sources where they say all
right well hold on just hold on this is
just the first shoe to drop Durham was
out there today he was testifying then
we're going to have Weiss and we have
other prosecutors in Delaware and
there's going to be other investigations
another Choice guys
guys yeah look we now live and Jack
passopic was talking about this on his
award-winning podcast human events
earlier today
that we now live in not a one not a two
but a three-tiered system of justice a
three-tiered system of justice this is
the thesis that poso was lining out uh
and it's simple because we knew we lived
in a two-tier right we we all got that
in 2016 when James Comey we remember
this right we remember when James go
there that's that's what gets me is that
everybody's acting like this is normal
everyone's acting like oh yeah well the
president's son gets a you know gets a
plea deal and it's just easy on a cop to
some of these you know tax charges and
so he lied to the ATF I mean look if any
of us lied to the ATF we'd get a deal
like this as well it's not it's called a
uh uh it's a pre-trial diversion
pre-trial diversion is what it's called
and it essentially means that he's
really sorry he admits that he did of
something very naughty and he's
definitely not going to do it again I
think that's the same thing that would
happen to any of us yeah if we lied
about I don't know our pistol braces if
we lied about our bump stocks if we lied
about shaving off uh or uh well there's
there's certain modifications that can
be made to a semi-automatic AR-15 that
we're definitely not going to talk about
here but we could talk about in the
members show that if you're listening
we're definitely going to have a
conversation about that and more but if
you lie to the ATF we all know what's
going to happen you're in trouble you
are going to get messed up and
there is now a two-tier system A
two-tiered system that is turned into a
third tier system because one tier
that's the proletariat that's the proles
that's the regulars that's the hoi pull
away that's everyone else
then there's a tear there's a tier for
the aristocracy there's a tier for the
the leadership the political preferred
class just as poso was outlining again
his award-winning podcast yeah really I
mean just just a smart and handsome how
does he do it yeah well no I mean he's
smart a beautiful family you know
beautiful family
beautiful family and he's smart I'll
give you that you know like cartoonists
yeah Family First Look I mean is that a
high bar if you want to set it there
yeah yeah give me that one more time
there's a three-tier system and then and
then there's a third tier and that third
tier is for people like Donald Trump but
not just Trump not just right Wingers
people like Julian Assange people who
are troublemakers to the regime people
for whom the the legal system the legal
standards get twisted into whatever
Arcane reading that lawyers and judges
will go along with to go after them a
paperwork dispute gets treated as if it
is uh handing over the nuclear codes to
Vladimir Putin we were being told Don
Junior was going to go to jail for the
rest of his life that's right that's
right down junior and so Donald Trump
call it too like early June wasn't he
said I guarantee you that they're going
to come after uh you know Hunter Biden
with like a small little slap to make it
seem like oh look the digestive system
is fair and actually I think the view
actually made a point of that they're
like oh look there no one's Above the
Law not even the president's son they
came after him and it's like come on
like you know imagine genuinely believe
imagine genuinely believing Justice is
served here that these are the penalties
that any other person in this country
would get if they were outside of that
narrow political class yeah he's the
Donald Trump is a Nostradamus every time
I'm just saying I try to think about
like when I first heard this story like
okay Hunter's getting getting off easy I
was like should he part of me was like
yeah he should Joe should have done the
right thing and put his son in jail for
20 years or 15 years for whatever 10
years I don't know what it is uh and
then I now I'm starting to question it I
don't even know if this is the way to go
is to start arresting everyone left and
right for her but I mean I don't know
what do you think but this is these
these are not minor things either right
so we see a lot of influence pedaling we
see a lot of political leaders trying to
profit off of their position or the
family members of political leaders
trying to profit off of their positions
and I think Hunter Biden did that in a
particularly egregious way which is
beyond the pal of what we usually see in
American politics for as bad as that
gets but on top of that Hunter Biden
didn't just commit crimes that are
outside the purview of what the average
American might do or what they could be
found guilty of or being put on trial
for so it's difficult to to outline the
fact that there's a two-tier system when
it comes to influence peddling because
your average person isn't really in a
position where they're going to be able
to do that so it's difficult to compare
the charge they would get to the charge
that someone who's the member of a
powerful political family would get but
when it comes to the the gun charges or
when it comes to the dealings with money
let's say to to put it euphemistically
and the fact that he hadn't I believe
reported his income for fully to the
tune of hundreds of thousands of dollars
uh Tim can fact check me on that one
there I mean these are things that even
in those amounts your average American
couldn't be capable of but they could
commit some variety of those crimes and
they would get in way more trouble for
it
well it's like Joe Buck President Joe
Biden said uh nobody FS with a with a
Biden all right or isn't that what he
said that's the thing though here's the
thing the very same people the very same
people that spent what did they spend
all last week doing when when that
prosecutor Jack Smith got up there at
the Department of Justice and he said
about Trump he said he they repeated one
refrain over and over the same refrain
you heard on MSNBC the same afraid you
heard on on every single network no one
is above the law no one is above the law
no one is above the law they were doing
that because they were front loading it
they were priming you psychologically to
prepare to respond exactly the way you
just said about Hunter Biden because
they want you thinking okay we did go
after Hunter Biden and it gives you a
false because it gives you an out to say
well that's not true Hunter Biden didn't
get off why look he was charged he
accepted a plea deal he had to do all of
these all of these different things he
had to pay the money back and they
looked into it and he was charged
therefore it's okay to go after Trump
but here's the thing Donald Trump isn't
going to be offered a plea deal that
means that Donald Trump's
he's not going to take a plea deal okay
there's nothing in Donald Trump's psyche
that would allow him to admit fault
admit any of this and he did an
interview with with Brett Bear and
there's people coming back and forth on
that saying oh it was great I think it's
a real shock test like so Trump
supporters are saying uh this was a
great interview this was wonderfully
knocked out of the park and then uh
Trump detracted her saying oh this is
terrible he's done he's done for he's
this is the end of trump the walls are
closing in his lawyers are committing
suicide as we watch uh you know he's
this is the end the end of trump and
then you've got people in the middle who
are like I still don't understand he's
why he's being charged because they
asked him about the classified documents
and he said he Declassified them and
they said he was was president when he
Declassified them and then he also said
oh by the way there were uh you know
socks and shoes and commemorable shirts
and different things in these boxes
because remember we're showing the
picture of the boxes
and yet we're not actually showing what
was in the Box yeah in fact you can't
see what's in the boxes but that's great
persuasion right visual persuasion look
at all of these boxes
they're full of exactly they're they're
just up to the brim with classified
documents Declassified I think that what
this shows is once again the Democrats
are using are willing to wield full
power and come after anyone I mean they
literally have the political leader of
the Republican right you know you can
argue that it might be DeSantis oh it's
time for Trump to step down Trump is
still the face of the Republican party
like there is no Maga without you know
Donald Trump right now that's just a
reality I and I hear this not just you
know I'm not from a red state I'm not in
a conservative state by any means I'm in
Los Angeles California regular people
like Street vendors that I talk to
they're just like no yeah Donald Trump
is the Republican he's that guy and so
what it kind of pisses me off a little
bit when I see that you know they're
coming after like Adam Schiff like
Republicans can't even do that
successfully coming after Adam Schiff
trying to censure him and I think that
you know last week we were just talking
about this uh they try to find them a
multi-million dollar dollars and and you
know Thomas Massey I think is a great
politician but he's like oh well we
don't want to open the floodgates we
don't want to have him pay a fine
because what what what happened if
Democrats came after us and they did
that and I'm like buddy like those days
are way over man you know what I mean
like we got to stop thinking that way
and I think that that's why
conservatives continue to lose all the
time because they're just well we don't
want to cross that line because you know
well what if they came and did it to us
we just went through three years of
tyranny medical Theory like it's just
insane that we're still thinking this
way I cannot believe that there are
still conservatives online saying well
we don't want to cross that line because
well you know what if they come back and
do it to us whenever they can power dude
they literally indicted the leader of
the Republican party you think they care
about the the average Republican out in
the street trying to you know blue
collar worker they don't they arrested
your leader and nothing has happened
like what are we doing here thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang hang out with us live
Monday through Friday at 8pm and become
a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time